Shin gentleman is recognized for five
minutes thank you madam chairman you may
recall that a few weeks ago President
Obama came to this chamber and he
addressed the chamber on health care
before a joint session of the house and
the Senate during that session I was
privileged to be here and I saw my
colleagues on the far side of the aisle
two Republicans waving pieces of paper
during his speech and I was wondering
what they were I couldn't imagine and
almost seemed like they wanted President
Obama's autograph I just didn't get it I
heard from one of my colleagues that
this is what they called the Republican
health care plan I went over after the
speech is over I picked up a copy that
was lying down on the Republican side
and it turns out that the Republicans
health care plan was a blank piece of
paper I inquired further trying to find
out exactly what the Republicans health
plan is and it's my duty and pride
tonight to be able to announce exactly
what the Republicans plan to do for
health care in America it's this very
simply it's a very simple plan here it
is the Republicans health care plan for
America don't get sick that's right
don't get sick if you have insurance
don't get sick if you don't have
insurance don't get sick if you're sick
don't get sick just don't get sick
that's what the Republicans have in mind
for you America that's the Republicans
health care plan but i think that the
republicans understand that that plan
isn't always going to work it's not a
foolproof plan so the republicans have a
back-up plan in case you do get sick if
you get sick in America this is what the
Republicans want you to do if you get
sick America the Republican healthcare
plan is this die quickly that's right
the Republicans want you to die quickly
if you get sick now the Democrats have a
different plan the Democrats say that if
you have health insurance we're going to
make it better if you don't have health
insurance we're going to provide it to
you if you can't afford health insurance
then we'll help you to afford health
insurance
so America gets the side do you want the
Democratic plan or do you want the
Republican plan remember the Republican
plan don't get sick and if you do get
sick die quickly thank you very much
madam Speaker